this weekend our ion money series we're
looking into some of the costly mistakes
people make with their finances many
families do not plan ahead for the care
of aging parents and the financial
burden often falls on adult children
nearly 3 and 10 Americans with a parent
65 or older say they have helped their
parents financially in the past year
according to a 2014 survey we spoke to
Jessica budae who has provided financial
support to her 64 year old father living
in another state I'm always saving I
know that it's been important to save
for retirement as soon as you start
working but 33 year-old Jessica budae
spends a lot of time planning for
retirement but not just her own
sometimes it's a bit awkward because you
feel like you're the child that's now
becoming more like a parent figure after
filing for bankruptcy several years ago
her father Mike is rebuilding his
finances these days we're talking a lot
about what his retirement might look
like there isn't going to be a
substantial amount of retirement savings
to live off of so it will be kind of a
fixed income situation
Jessica an only child of divorced
parents now acts as a safety net for her
father if there were to be a major
medical expense that could be something
where he would require some support in
the last year he has purchased a condo
so I did provide some support to ensure
that transaction could happen
it was the same if not a bit cheaper
than renting Jessica dipped into her own
savings to help purchase the home she
and boyfriend Shawn factored in support
like this when planning their own future
you don't know where we may have to make
a big investment it could be because of
supporting a parent it could be that we
want to buy a home and maybe even
because of past experience with my
family we are more on the conservative
side of our budget CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger writes about
caring for your aging parents in her new
book the dumb thing smart people do with
their money thirteen ways to write your
financial wrongs she's also a certified
financial planner Jill good morning
Jessica's worried about her father you
say you're worried about Jessica oh my
well I mean I think she did an amazing
job she actually had a tough
conversation with her dad too
kind of figure out what's going on she
created a plan she talked about renting
versus buying but I'm worried because
now I'm thinking we'll wait a second she
used this money for her dad's condo what
about her own place of residence what if
she wants to buy now she may be
prevented from doing some things that
she wanted to do because her dad needed
help so when I get her dad it is her dad
and I want her to take care of him but I
think if I could wind the clock back I
would have said look I know renting
might be a little bit more expensive but
I would have rather her kept that
liquidity that extra money floating
around because as she said she might
need it for him she also might need it
for herself and she points out to having
expand through this with myself the
medical expenses if you have one of
these they are extraordinary and they
put you in a tough place where you have
to make choices about someone you love
dearly and your pocketbook yes and I
think that the reason why we want to
raise this as an issue is that we want
to foster conversations because what
you're trying to figure out is hey mom
dad tell me how you're doing are you
living paycheck to paycheck I'd rather
know that you know Gail and I were
talking in the green room we were saying
it's really hard for parents to share
that kind of information they may not
come to you you want to figure out
what's going on do they have an
emergency reserve fund what are they
thinking about for their own housing do
they want to stay where they are are
they gonna move in with you are they
going to maybe try to rent for a while
let's get this information out so we can
all be prepared both generations but why
is it such an awkward conversation
because I don't think parents want to
ask their kids for help and I think I
was raised in a house and you don't
discuss money with your parents yeah I
think that this is a real issue because
I think that there is a bit of shame
around it because if I'm the parent I
don't want to put that burden on my kid
on the other hand as a child you want to
you don't want to be seen as kind of
nudging your parents so what I say is
you've got to have these conversations
no matter what we want to reveal the
information we want you to be
transparent we want you to get the the
bottom line what can we do to actually
prepare for this if you don't know how
to start this conversation the best
thing to script yeah exactly so here's
what you do you say I was watching CBS
this morning and
interesting segment about this and you
use that as a trigger or you say
something about someone you know hey my
friend's mom just moved in or you might
say it's tax season how did you do in
the tax season how are you doing and
it's you how how stark should one be in
these conversations because I mean you
don't want to go all the way to you know
when you're in ur Singh home are you
going to be okay sharing a room yes
that's I know and are we because though
I mean it can get pretty brutal pretty
fast yes and I think that the first way
to have the conversation is to know
you're having a conversation but you
can't be judgmental you don't want your
parents to be judgmental about you you
open the door you have a conversation
you nudge it open then once it's open
you don't push too far again what are
you trying to figure out how are you
doing day to day what do you have in
that emergency reserve and by the way
what are your plans going forward now if
they push back guess what
don't go there the door is now open a
tiny bit you can walk through when
necessary be kind to one another this is
a really tough sign this always works
you say retirees make common financial
mistakes that impact their kids well I'm
talking about one thing I think is
incredibly important that there are a
lot of people who are just putting their
homes in their kids names this can be
very dangerous there are tax
consequences to doing this a lot of
people are doing it without their kids
knowing so before you make a big
financial decision like I'm just gonna
put the house in my kids name make sure
you talk to somebody get some third
party to help you out well I will say
Jessica's lucky to have a boyfriend like
Sean who's going to help her father out
he's a keeper oh yeah thank you and if
you have questions about making a plan
to care for your aging parents head over
to CBS this morning Facebook page and
Jill will answer some of those questions
and if you have been misled by past
financial advice or bought a home when
you should have rented consider sharing
your story to help other viewers you
need to find a submission form at CBS
News comm slash costly mistakes